têtu de ipsos mené dans 27 pays
mais dont les résultats français nous
intéresse tout particulièrement parce
qu'il indique qu'il y a une forte
défiance envers les médias
48% des français considèrent ainsi que
les journaux et les magazines véhicules
fréquemment des fausses informations
ça monte à 52 % pour la télévision et la
radio c'est quand même important il ya
plus d'un français sur deux considère
que la télévision et la radio disent
fréquemment des choses fausses et à dire
nous mentent et il n'y a qu'un gros
tiers des français qui ont confiance
aujourd'hui dans leurs médias
daniel bilalian d'abord est-ce que c'est
nouveau ça ou est-ce que ce que ça
toujours et que j'avais jamais vu de
sondages de cette importance je pense
que oui c'est relativement nouveau
moi mon avis il ya plusieurs raisons
alors il yad'abord internet
je pense que c'est un des phénomènes
essentiel c'est quand même internet
permet quand même à des gens qui avaient
rien à dire de le faire savoir
quand même ça le début de la fin pas
seulement mais ça permet aussi et ça
permet d'aider ça permet de déverser et
alors il ya un phénomène c'est celui de
l'information continue la formation
continue est à mon avis mais beaucoup
n'ont pas été pas du tout je n'ai rien
contre je n'ai réussi j'ai content parce
que je le problème de l'information
continue c'est que ces stations de radio
ont besoin de gasoil toute la journée
pour y tourner et de télévision donc il
faut qu'ils aient quelque chose regardez
les matins où il le soleil s'est levé
simplement ils s'ennuient jusqu'à mille
îles heureusement à midi il ya eu un
coup de couteau donc d'un seul coup ça
redémarre donc c'est ça le vrai problème
c'est l'information continue quand vous
êtes obligés d'aller monter avec des
queues de cerises comme dit ma mère ils
font des clafoutis
c'est ça le vrai danger le vrai danger
il est là il est la machine génération
qui a connu
l'information qui est l information du
matin du midi du soir avec une sélection
qui était fait parfois à tort ou à
raison mais il y avait pas ce
déferlement en d'informations sur des
sujets qui n'ont aucun intérêt qui
perturbe les gens qui sont générale
basée d'abord en plus sur l'émotion
l'émotion est quelque chose de terrible
regarder ses photos 2d des milliers
d'immigrés qui se retrouve mort le long
de le long de la côte comme ça avait été
le cas d'un enfant il ya quelques années
bon c'est une chose mais on doit pas
travailler l'information sur des motions
on doit analyser pourquoi ils étaient là
pourquoi ça s'est passé comme ça est-ce
qu'ils avaient raison d'être là vers des
comptes les questions qu'il faut se
poser
aujourd'hui vous aurez posé des
questions comme celle ci on vous envoie
en vous disant que vous êtes quelqu'un
qui est inhumain etc
on est émotion réactions et les
journalistes en plus en plus jeunes
générations ont un problème avec les
mots par exemple françois fillon a été
pendant tous les temps de sa campagne
tous les soirs il y avait quinze type
qui jouait du tambour devant devancé
dans ses meetings et donc et si sur les
stations d'information en continu et
ailleurs d'ailleurs c'était nouvelles
manifestations ce soir sans personne
c'est un attroupement s'est pas du tout
la même chose c'est pas du tout la même
chose
les mots outranciers regarder les titres
des journaux
la canicule il fait chaud figurez-vous
qu'il fait chaud en juillet et on nous
propose peut-être de la neige en
décembre tous les militants j'ai un lien
il ya là pour vendre il faut être
spectaculaire dans les mots quand je dis
attroupement et pas manifestation ça un
sens ça a un sens et je pense par
ailleurs que il est effectivement plus
facile de faire circuler l'information
aujourd'hui et peut-être de se grouper
pour que ces informations soient
diffusés un mouvement comme les gilet
jaune ya 20 ans il fallait monter une
association fournir des tracts fait à
faire venir les gens aujourd'hui vous
faites sur internet vous faites
n'importe quelle information sur
internet et les gens se précipitent et
ça devient une information
il avait été surpris par les résultats
de cette enquête ou autour de vous quand
vous dites que vous êtes journaliste
les gens remarquent aussi de la défiance
alors peut-être je le ferai comme
peut-être des gens qui sont pas
représentatifs des français mais je suis
assez lucide sur sa nuque j'ai pas été
très surpris par ce sondage mais c'est
vrai que dès qu'on parle à des gens qui
sont un peu de moins de notre milieu
social privilégié il ya un mouvement de
recul quand on dit les journalistes mais
ceci dit moi je peux le comprendre tout
ce qu'a dit daniel bilalian jeu source
qui en partie j'ajouterai autre chose
c'est le sentiment qu'ont les français
et à mon avis n'ont pas forcément tort
que
le spectre d'opinion représentés dans
les médias ne correspond pas à celui qui
existe dans la population
puis il ya beaucoup d'opinions autorisé
dans la population qu'ils ne sont pas
dans les médias que en rétrécissement de
ses opinions autorisé par exemple je
prends un exemple frédéric taddéï et qui
animait une émission de débat sur france
2 maintenant ils obligés d'aller à la
télévision russe quand même entre
château dalle france pour faire son
émission avec des gens qui ont des
points de vue un petit peu diversité de
pluralisme
voilà et je pense qu'il ya aussi ça va
toujours en tirant même sens je prends
deux trois petits exemples mais
référendum 2005 95 % de la presse défend
le oui élections 2010 cette
présidentielle on peut quand même dire
sans trop s'avancer que les manuels
macron était le candidat préféré de
beaucoup de médias et gilet jaune
on a quand même moi je suis allé sur des
ronds points par léhady gilet jaune
quand je voyais la télévision continue
les qualifiés de racistes antisémites
homophobes et c'est que je comparais
avec la réalité de ce que je constate
sur le terrain je me suis dit il ya un
décalage et au bout d'un moment
ces décalages forcément il se paye dans
l'opinion il ya un manque de confiance
qui est peut-être un peu excessif parce
que si on fait plus confiance comme le
lis ton âge à ses proches ou aux réseaux
sociaux que comédienne je suis pas sûr
que ce soit plus en plus fiables au
voisin sauf que le média voisins il a
appris quelque chose je sais pas comment
voilà c'est un peu excessif mais je
pense que sa part d'un sentiment
légitime
oui côté ce commentaire de dinde et
patron d'ipsos
qui nous dit alors qu'il n'a jamais été
aussi facile d'accéder à l'information
où que ce soit ou qu'elles soient dans
le monde
c'est comme si finalement ce sont
finalement les règles de la proximité
qui s'applique comme si seul le bouche à
oreille au sens propre pouvait inspirer
confiance
seuls les relations personnelles ont
gagné en fiabilité au cours des cinq
dernières années
oui la nation 13h20 très très
embarrassant parce que j'ai le bonheur
d'être invité par les médias meanstream
j'ai vu comme vous savez vous allez
proposer je vous en remercie encore de
suivre
l'acte iv de gilet jaune pour le figaro
magazine etc
cependant je pense que les français que
s'expriment dans à travers ce sondage
ipsos ont raison ils ont raison ils ont
raison pour une raison très simple la
crise et gilet jaune à manifester le
fait que les médias audiovisuels
diffusés transformation ils ont diffusé
chaque samedi chaque samedi ils ont
repris les chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur que n'importe quel imbécile
regardant une photo de manifestations
vous savez quels étaient ces chiffres
étaient faux ces chiffres étaient faux
sur france info les chiffres diffusés
par l'édile
on a eu deux minimes i mais zizou ne
sont pas des médias a précisé ban et
signale que j'ai des jeunes montent
comme les syndicats mans tout comme les
parties prenantes
les médias ont comme les historiens une
recherche de la vérité
on sait très bien que chaque chiffre
attend des excuses moi chaque chiffre
concernant la les effectifs des
manifestations voilà des jugements de
valeur ça m est un portail internet a le
droit d'avoir son opinion mais des
chiffres d une conception factuel la
participation numérique aux
manifestations on reprenait
systématiquement les chiffres mais ce à
l'intérieur
ne me dites pas qu'on ne pouvait pas
faire autrement je vais prendre une
photo il suffit de comparer inversement
lorsqu'on avait des chiffres incroyables
mangou re grossit comme pour la
manifestation des foulards rouges jeter
les foulards ou jeu la roja auquel j'ai
assisté également
on voyait bien que ces chiffres étaient
totalement tordue autre élément très
intéressant le 1er mai le 1er mai
dernier et premier met donc en 2019
c est pas si longtemps en fait et bien
là il ya une fête news qui sort
l'unissent à l'intérieur sur l' attaque
on a pitié salpêtrière qui est repris
par les médias
j'étais sur place non pas dans la
tendance dans le périmètre de l'hôpital
mais sur la voie publique avec deux
journalistes du figaro nous savions que
c'était faux nous savions que c'était
faux sion réaction non non non non pas
par l'émotion à réaction on savait que
c'était faux on salue me sens matériel
reste amer le savait qu'est ce que dira
évidemment ou alors il faut que
démissionner lors du démissionnaire et
24 ans étaient incompétents n'importe
qui savait que c'était faux qui a pas eu
d'attaqué a dit il parle d' attaques de
l'hôpital d'agression des personnels
attendez ce n'est pas rien or on sait
que c'est faux s'est repris et c'est
grâce à internet
c'est grâce aux réseaux sociaux que la
vérité apparaît et donc comme l'a titré
à l'époque libération la fecq news
venait de l'intérieur
la fecq news est repris par les médias
est contredite par les réseaux sociaux
et s'il ya une telle volonté de
contrôler
mais entendu les réseaux sociaux c'est
bien entendu pour avoir un contrôle de
la vérité la censure est un modèle hors
voilier à l'information
donc évidemment les français essayent de
résister mais encore une fois ils seront
battus les lois qui sont mises en place
actuellement permettront effectivement
une censure de l'information de
décentraliser d'information sur internet
alors j'aimerais faire une remarque de
la fondation jean jaurès pour essayer
d'expliquer les sondages extrêmement
grossier dans la délation quart d'heure
alors j'aimerais faire une remarque du
thème franchement le tambour est faux
répondent et des sondages que vous
publiez ils sont incroyablement si je
fais marcher au pas des médias en ont
parlé des institutions d'âge aussi une
autre fois c'est gentil ça
m'intéresserait effectivement on pourra
se donner le change
une remarque et de commentaires la
remarque d'abord c'est que c'est quand
même d'un sondage qui est évidemment qui
ne fait qu'exprimer une inquiétude et on
peut tous et particulièrement inquiète
effectivement de voir qu'il ya
aujourd'hui une défiance puissante en
direction de la presse et des médias
donc on personne peut s'en réjouir les
deux commentaires je veux faire ils sont
peut-être eu un peu contradictoire mais
j'ai essayé de dépasser les
les aimants vous avez posé alors je vais
rejoindre ce que disait monsieur
bilalian effectivement la question est
aujourd'hui posée de l'information en
continu elle pose problème y compris
parce qu'on est dans un surplus
d'informations qui pousse au
sensationnalisme
on sait que une fausse nouvelle devait
atteint siffler en six fois plus vite le
même nombre de personnes qu une vraie
nouvelle parce qu'on est dans un monde
où d'une certaine manière il ya
tellement il ya de la mandature chiffres
abad étude américaine
non mais non mais alors pour vous c'est
beau comme l'annoncé très bon non les
mêmes études qui montrent qu'aujourd'hui
sur les réseaux sociaux vous avez sur
twitter plus souvent qu'une bonne
nouvelle oui vous avez 6 x 2 6 fois plus
de possibilité enfin vous avez six fois
plus vite quand vous avez une fausse
nouvelle
une vraie nouvelle pourquoi c'est parce
qu'une vraie nouvelle ça n'a pas grand
intérêt parce que comme le dit comme le
disais tout à l'heure monsieur vidal ion
savoir que le soleil se lève qui est une
ce qui est une vraie nouvelle tous les
matins ne fait pas pour beaucoup de
médias par contre vraiment intéressante
il ya des mêmes qui sont intéressants
plus puissants voiture a donc
objectivement c'est ça c'est déjà un
problème si le surplus d'informations et
le deuxième problème qui nous est posée
si on va un peu plus loin dans la
réflexion en réalité et ça c'est quelque
chose qui n'est pas abordée c'est que je
crois qu'aujourd'hui on est dans un
monde de désintermédiation et qu'on pose
la question et c'est peut-être un des
aimants qui posera sondages c'est ont
fait est ce qu on fait le procès des
informations le procès des médias c'est
pas la même chose
et la question qui est posée aujourd'hui
dans l'univers mais des médias comme
d'ailleurs dans l'univers du politique
c'est con on est dans le mythe de la
société désintermédiés c'est à dire que
une information l ai vu qui est vécu
comme brut est aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
vous vous l'avez vu les mouvements
sociaux où l'action politique
il faut qu on la gère directement tout
ce qui fait preuve de médiation c'est à
dire les élus les syndicats les
corporations la presse qui sont censés
être capable de pouvoir justement donner
à voir et traite une information
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui
n'existe plus ou qui en situation de
faiblesse dans notre société
et moi je crois que la question qui doit
nous est posée c'est d'abord réaffirmé
le fait qu'il faut qu'ils aient de la
médiation dans la société est un des
acteurs de la médiation ce sont les
médias les médias ils sont là
normalement pourquoi retraités une
information y compris quelquefois
assumer un parti-pris sert qu'une
information elle n'existe pas en soi et
je crois que c'est peut-être face à
cette défiance un peu puissante qui est
posée aujourd'hui par ce type de sondage
ça pose un défi à la presse actuelle c
est ce qu'elle est capable de rouge de
rejouer et d'assumer ce rôle de
médiation et deuxièmement d'assumer ce
rôle de parti pris moi en tout cas c'est
ce que je souhaiterais que ce qu'on
puisse avoir comme débat au delà de
savoir si aujourd'hui il faut avoir peur
de la presse ou considérer qu'elle
instrumentalise désobéissants vouloir
critiquer ma profession
mais quand même je voudrais vous donner
un exemple qui me concerne directement
il ya sur mon idée de émotions réaction
est plus d' analyse il ya deux ans en
2016 j'ai assuré le commenter en direct
de l'inauguration des jeux olympiques de
rio
à un moment donné on parlait de la
présence portugaise et jeudi les
portugais ont estimé que l'esclavagé
était nécessaire pour le développement
du brésil
le cran ce cet organisme qui une fois
regroupé 300 personnes ce public publie
un communiqué disant monsieur lui ayant
estimé à dikhil l'exclavage avaient été
nécessaires au développement du brésil
ils sont ça ça se passe un dimanche soir
le lundi ils sont reçus par ma
présidente qui gentiment lieu de me
prévenir les reçoit ensuite ils sont
reçus par le csa heureusement essai paru
dans le parisien bilalian et pour le
scld lavage
heureusement j'ai un confrère de
l'express qui le mercredi non j'ai
écouté il dit simplement que les
portugais avaient estimé que l'esclavagé
était nécessaire au développement du
brésil vous rendez compte on y voit en
des comptes
ils ont été reçus et aimer même le cssa
qui aurait dû leur dû a goûté vous êtes
gentils vous n'avez qu'à écouter journée
oui il faut que les journalistes
tiennent compte pour le coup les médias
entrée que des officiels était plus
crédible que l'oeil que les réseaux
sociaux voilà ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure
moment me renvoie sur un point au
libéralisme le plus total en matière
d'information se dire qu'il veut
effectivement qu'il ya une concurrence
des médias les médias français sont
soumis à des règles liées à leur
actionnariat et au fait qu'ils vivent
dans un espace national les
vous êtes enfin concernés s'étaient
france télévisions c'est lié de fait des
médias d'état ça se fait en russie en
turquie on dirait des médias d'état
d'avoir des médias du régime on dirait
lorsqu'elle a est bien ce qu'il est bon
c'est le pluralisme la contradiction
comme pour les sondages d'ailleurs
pourquoi est ce que les sondages à mon
avis devises après la vérité est ce
qu'on est en hiver de concurrence et
donc il faut qu'il ait une concurrence
par rapport à des médias français des
médias étrangers défaut d'information
justement sur internet et tout ce qui
paraîtra de lutter contre l'échec news
sera justement le développement de ce
libéralisme d'information de cette
concurrence et qu'inversement les lois
d'état
les lois de censure qui sont prises
actuellement ne faut que nous éloigner
de la vérité mais ça nous ramène à
l'aise quand même que trop
d'informations tué l'information en
france il y avait pas station
d'information continue radiotélévision
ce que dans 2000
nous en avons quatre aujourd'hui les
américains qui sont 200 millions
d'habitants dans l'octroi ses papilles
merci on part d'un autre sujet si vous
le voulez bien le tour de france ça
commence demain il va partir de
bruxelles
est ce que cette épreuve a perdu de son
aura avant de vous entendre
je vous propose d'écouter béatrice
houchard c'est une consoeur qui
journaliste politique qui est bien bien
connu pour ça à la fois au figaro puis à
l'opinion elle parlait de cette épreuve
un peu égratignée c'était dans
l'émission conversation du figaro live
je pense que les français sont victimes
d'une première chose qui est pour le
coup la mondialisation c'est-à-dire
pendant des dizaines et des dizaines
d'années le cyclisme c'était les
français les italiens les belges et les
néerlandais un petit peu les allemands
ensuite les espagnols et c'était tout
forcément ça laisse moins de chances là
que la concurrence est plus est